with a mysterious new villain a surprise
twist and big changes for all our
favorite characters the witcher season 2
has tons of details we need to discuss
yippie kai movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm explaining everything you
might have missed in the ending of
season two and what it all means for
season three spoilers ahead of course so
take care
key to understanding the season two
finale is the deathless mother aka
volithmere a demon who takes possession
of siri according to vesamir the first
witch has imprisoned volothmir in a hut
long ago one of the oldest monsters a
demon she wreaked havoc until the
witches bound her deep in the forest
however the demon woke from her slumber
after siri's scream split the monolith
outside sintra she begins by appearing
in the dreams of jennifer franjilla and
queen of the elves francesca and
manipulates their fears and personal
pain for jennifer the demon taunts her
about her loss of power after sodom hill
and promises it back if she takes siri
to the broken monolith by sintra for
fringilla the deathless mother spurs her
on to take power for herself by forming
an alliance with the elves this leads
the nilf guardians to mistrust the
sorceress and when she uncovers their
plot and takes revenge you can hear
volothmere cackling in the background
feeding off the pain and destruction
she's sewn as for francesca the demon
takes the form of the legendary elven
prophet ethelene who preys on her
insecurity about never having brought a
baby to term and promises she'll finally
give birth to a pure elven child however
when francesca's baby is cruelly
assassinated the deathless mother revels
in her suffering which gives her the
energy to break free from her prison in
the hut the newly liberated demon seeks
out siri possesses her and begins to
murder the witches at kerr [ __ ] one by
one notice how she uses the same dagger
she used to kill an early witcher
cleffier was one of the first witchers
that's what she used to kill him so
volithmere is basically using the same
dagger to enact revenge on the school of
witchers who locked her away all those
years ago although geralt arrives to try
to break siri out of the deathless
mother's possession the demon is able to
keep control of her by offering her an
alternate world in her mind where she
can be with loved ones she's lost and
fans of the haunting of bly manor will
notice some interesting parallels here
with that horror story volothmir then
uses siri's scream to split open the
witcher medallion tree revealing a stone
monolith which she splits into shards
that attack the witchers before creating
a portal that pulls through a pair of
basilisk monsters from another world
which she sets upon the witches in fact
this moment was foreshadowed in the
fifth episode when tris and siri
journeyed into the valley of siri's soul
and siri began to call out to geralt who
was with istrid at the site of the
shattered monolith outside sintra
as garrett called out the medallion trio
care [ __ ] began to crack and vibrate a
clue to the hidden stone inside and
shards of the monolith outside sintra
flew into the air and opened up a
gateway that released another monster
istrid who'd been researching monoliths
discovered that they were all connected
and that on the same day siri destroyed
the first stone another monolith began
to vibrate something which led to a new
theory about what happened during the
conjunction of spheres the event that
collided worlds together if the original
spheres are still out there somewhere
and our monoliths are calling to them
then the monsters aren't new they're
using arm on lists as gateways although
the witch has managed to slay the
basilisk the deathless mother remains
firmly in control of siri keeping her
tucked away in the happy memories of her
long dead family i'm staying right here
forever geralt realizes the only option
is to find an alternate vessel to siri
to contain the demon which leads to yen
sacrificing herself in a call back to
her attempted suicide in season one
something also foreshadowed in her
vision with the deathless mother for
yennefer this is the moment to right the
wrong she did to siri by almost
delivering her to volathmia and the
spell she cast pulls the demon out of
syrian into her notice how jen's eyes
finally become purple again at this
point because this is the moment her
magic returns after being de-powered for
most of the second season i felt it come
back when i when you sacrifice yourself
for siri next though to get the monster
out of yennefer syria uses her own
powers to take herself geralt and yen
into another world as they all land on
another sphere the demon leaves yen and
reforms itself as one of a group of
apocalyptic riders which fans of the
witcher 3 game and the books will
recognize as the wild hunt the wild hunt
is a group of antagonists who are
associated with being an omen of doom
appearing before or during times of war
and they were mentioned this way a
couple of times in season two
they're known for traveling between
realms and kidnapping people to use as
slaves and they're clearly after siri
specifically because of her exceptional
powers child of the elder blood
starry-eyed daughter of chaos join our
hunt your place is among us by the way
not only does the reddish coloring of
this world give it a hellish apocalyptic
feel but it may also be an allusion to
the name red riders that the wild hunter
sometimes known by
the wild hunt also appeared during the
journey into siri's deep subconscious
when she discovered she's a descendant
of lara doran notice the little blue
flowers here around the dying elf which
only grow where elder blood has been
spilled like the ones which grew from
siri's blood around care morin laura
doram was an elven sorceress who had a
child with a human mage however their
union was controversial among both
humans and elves which led to lara's
persecution when estrid visits cod
ringer and fenn he learns about the
curse lara placed before she died my
curse will hound your descendants and to
the tenth generation until the columns
of time and space tremble and open for
my people then my vengeance will be born
again the curse alludes to siri's
screams and her effect on the monoliths
which have now opened portals in space
and time that allow interdimensional
travel and it also ties in with
ethelene's prophecy that predicts the
end of the world a part of which lara
doran recites to siri during her mind
journey with tris the world will die
amidst frost and be reborn of the new
sun reborn of elder blood of the seed
that has been sown a seed that will not
sprout but will burst into flame elder
blood is a gene that tends to pass on
more in the female line and although
kolanthe possessed it herself the queen
tried to suppress knowledge of her elven
heritage and siri witnesses that fear
when she sees her mother and father
arguing over the discovery of siri's
elven descent they'd kill her if they
knew it's a prophecy maybe it's not true
it doesn't matter if it's true it only
matters if the people believe it and
dooney was right because triss is truly
terrified after what she sees in siri
and reports the matter back to the
brotherhood of aratusa who by the end of
the season decide to place a bounty on
siri and anyone protecting her
and talking of dooney the big twist
reveal at the end is that siri's father
is still alive and is actually emperor
amir aka the white flame in fact there
was a little hint in siri's dream world
that her father was still alive because
notice how everyone from mousek to
kalanthae and pavetta fade away to dust
but he does not siri and her family had
assumed dooney died on the sea voyage he
took with his wife however there's a
secret reason why he survived which will
take us into likely season 3 spoiler
territory so you can skip forward to
this time stamp in case you don't want
to know just yet in the books dooney
planned to use the sea voyage as a way
to secretly disappear with pavetta and
siri to nilfgaard by faking their death
at sea with the assistance of the mage
vilgefortz however when pavetta
discovered the plan she decided to get
siri off the boat before it set sail
this led to an argument later at sea
where dooney accidentally pushed pavetta
overboard where she drowned vilgefortz
then ported dooney and himself off the
boat which led everyone to assume that
dooney had also died on the trip in the
meantime dooney returned to reclaim his
position as emperor of nilfgaard as well
as his former name amir
another twist emir reveals is that he
was the one who ordered the murder of
francesca's elven baby which meant he
knew that kahir and frangilla were lying
to him so they ended up carted off by
nilfgaardian soldiers having the baby
killed sends francesca and the elves
north to nilfgaard's enemy rodania who
they believe are to blame for the baby's
death and francesca carries out some
infanticide of her own as she casts a
spell killing all of rodania's babies
francesca also later discovers from
estrid that siri is henikir the elven
term for elder blood which means the
elves too now will be looking for the
princess in season three as they will
see her as a possible savior who can
liberate them from human persecution
and lurking in the background of this
moment and many others in season two is
dexter's spy owl who is finally revealed
as philippa at the very end i'm saying
word is out about the girl things just
got more fun forever philippa is a
sorceress in the redanian court with the
ability to polymorph herself into an owl
notice also the owl feathers on her
costume and the talon-shaped ring on her
hand although vizimir is the king in
rodania it seems like dextra together
with philippa are the ones really
pulling the strings in the kingdom given
visimir's overall apathetic attitude to
important matters speaking of which i'm
starving diegstro get to the point but
there's still another twist to reveal
when deekstra tells philippa bring me
the bard it's about time he paid back
his benefactor the extra doesn't mention
yaskir by name but it's heavily implied
that the famous bard loved and hated by
geralt appears to now be on the redanian
payroll this is surprising as i didn't
detect any real hints of an alternate
agenda during yasuki's scenes in season
two and my best guess is that his fame
with his toss a coin to your witcher
song puts him on dykstra's radar as
someone who could potentially spy on the
witchers that also be a new bard who's
revealed as a spy in season three
another pair of characters with their
own agenda arians and lydia riyans was
initially in jail for crimes during
kalanthae's reign but when nilfgaard
took over the city lydia came to him
with an offer of freedom in return for
hunting down siri during this mission he
ended up getting half his face burned by
yennefer an interesting change from the
books which i explained in my easter
eggs and things you missed video riyans
managed to steal the vial of siri's
blood from keremorin which he took to
lydia who attempted to perform blood
tracing on the sample this went badly
for her as we discovered in the finale
where we see she suffered significant
injuries from the experiment that burned
off part of her face and now she can
only communicate telepathically i won't
let you down again my lord as for whom
riance and lydia are talking to i
strongly suspect in season three it'll
be revealed to be vilgefortz in the
books lydia is the mages personal
assistant and secretary and there are
clues in the show that vilgefortz has a
hidden agenda at the end of the first
season he decided to murder a northern
soldier even though he'd gone with the
rest of the brotherhood to sodom to
defend the north against the
nilfgaardian attack and in season 2 he
begins to act strangely around taseo
whenever the subject of siri comes up
and he seems to be obsessed with trying
to uncover what to say and might be
hiding about the princess i wouldn't ask
you to if it wasn't necessary i expect
in season three now that amir's identity
as siri's father's been revealed vilger
forces true intentions and what he's
getting in return from the emperor will
also be disclosed i'm looking forward to
seeing more of the rodanian intelligence
network and philippa's house vine next
season however in real life you might be
troubled to know that your own internet
service provider may be spying on you
and logging all your online activity
which is why i want to thank the sponsor
of this video nordvpn who offer one of
the world's best virtual private
networks like the witch's powerful quen
sign that protects against evil forces a
vpn protects your privacy by encrypting
your internet connection and preventing
your internet service provider the
government or snoopers from knowing what
websites you're visiting and from
reading your private messages and it's
also a powerful tool that can help you
bypass geolocation blocks so that you
can access content not available to view
or censored in your country just pick a
server in another location and browse
the internet as if you were there
something we especially like about nord
is the super fast download speeds on its
5 000 plus servers and how it uses
next-gen vpn technologies like wire
guard you can connect up to six devices
at the same time including your laptop
tablet desktop phone and home router so
you can cover all of your connected
devices and with our exclusive holiday
offer you can get a huge 73 percent of a
two-year plan plus one month free just
visit
nordvpn.comflix or tap the link in the
video description to access the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out so what do you think about the
witch's second season and do you have
any theories for season three let me
know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this then do leave a thumbs up i
really appreciate it next tap left to
discover all the easter eggs and crazy
details you may have missed in season 2.
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie kai movie lovers